SUNDAY.
M HILLIP.
WOMEN OF CNG AGE IN
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THEY LIVED
HEE
THN MOVES
, COALL R EFFO TY AT IT AND ELIN
EE T
>> I'M ANGRY, I'RED UP
GHT IS NOTE US 50 YEARS, BWE'LLN
GULF BETWEEN REDND BLUE AT
ME.T TO WHAHENSTITUTIAL
RIGHTS COULD BE IN THE CROSS  TE
STATES FRA TO
>> THE WOMB IS IHOMA
SAFEST P A
B
OKLAHOMA'SR LA ACTIV
WITH RO TO
STATES VIRTUALLY BANNING ALLABO
THAT COULD NLAWS
S RIGHT TOSULTS  IFAUSINEI TO MI
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM IS ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER JOINIS
MUCRE, LEIGH N LL OF THE "WASH
," MANU JUND
E
BEEN TALKING ABOUT
VEONTE LIKE  T THINK THAER MEN A
D STATESRE
NOW QUESTIONING WHAT LIFE IS
GOING TO BE LIKE FOR THEM UNDER
THIS NEWULCT?
>>NK THEACT IND OF
R AS T WILSH
WE HEARDROT BIDEON
PROTECT THE FROFAVEL ACROSS STAR
PEOPLE TO IVTH
BUT I THONE QUESTION THAT
REMAINS REALLYAN STATES MAY
TRY TO FIGHTAINSS THATOCSTATSTRI
TI POINT. SOLVED
S BEEN SNG
PEOPLER COLLGUE
BROWTECRIBED THE LAST 50
YEASREVOLUTION,
ERHTS COURTS IPATHRIGHTS, N
T WOMEN'RIGHTS, THOSE G ROIN
STAT IL E THIS INE
FRONTIER.
ON WAR
BETWEEN THE STATES ARE ALREADYR
ES ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW  R
MAKE  TO
REE  DO.ATEST 2 WEEK R 15 WEEBA
>> W POI
SS M THE
COUNTRY THERE ARE MANY
STATES WHERERTN ACCESS WASY .
ES LIK, DOWN TING
HANDFUL OF PROCEDURES A MONTH
E  YEARS.
TRAVELING ANTHIENTS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS LOWER
INOFOR,
IT IS GOIN ONLY GE
EEHED. E SEE AN ESCATION OAU  L
LOOK AT THE ERS.E E AND -- YOUNO
THESE ARE BIG S.
NAPA
ISE IN, THMBS STAR
PUBLIC OPINIAD TOVERTURN ROE V.
34% OFMERICANS SAID YES,
IN A MAY POLL.
6 6% SAID .
N'SH
HOLE LOT IN THE LAST
FEW YEARYEAV
IANS I
WASHN McCARTHY
SAYING NOW HG TOO FO
A N BAN.WHAT HAPPENE LEATOTHE S?
SKEDHA
THNG T DEBAT
PAY HOW FA GO.
BOTH OE ATD ON
THE STATLE D ANDBORTIO
EXCEPTIONS FOR THE LIFE OF THE H
TIO D
TAKE THE T E, THEY TRY TO PUT A
BILL THAULN ABORTION AT
SOME LEVEL, McLOT OF PRESSFR
EVEN THOERE WILL N B
SIEDBY DEMOCRATIC
T IS GOING T AMONG REPUBLICANS
AND THE QUESTION IE
HO WHAT NDF IMPA
F MONAVIN DEBATE, THE
THE MIDTERMS WILE WHO
SOME KEY RACES, PARTICUL TH ON
PLACES LIKE WIZO, BIONBET
E RACES, SOME BIG S RACETOO.
>> AND -S HAPPENING AS
AND THERE IS SOME CONSTERNATION
SUBURBANCIALLY I
AMONG WOMEN.
I DONOTHAT AREE
REPUBLANWATH
LEGISLATION ON ASA
S OLITICE THEYBO HAVING TH
ON
THE SAMME FOR CISUHEY
THOUGHT' THE
TABLE, BECAUHE
" "THE NEW YORK TIMES," KNOW -
WS ONSIBLE FO
D T
ATMIT
MIDTERMS.
THEY'RE REPORTING THAT HE THINKS
WOULD  FORPU DEMOCRARE UN ON TH.
BUT  GET THE SENSE CTAINTY ABOU
>> I THINK ABO WHO I
UFT REALLY.
NOBODYWE HEARDREOTHE LROISN THB.
NTIALLY THE ME SAY, LIKE, YOUN
CTIS
THE LEFT, PROGSS
LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN VOTINGND
THERE NS
ABOUT WHETHER OR N
ACTUALLY A SUFFITHING LING PEOPH
>> WE'RE GOOD TO SEE A TURNING .
AS BEE
E RIGH20 CAMPA T
OF US WH
ALKING TNY VOTERS  TMI
>> H, U UE VERT AND ABORW THEY E
CLOSELY.
A LOT OF R
SAYING THEY'RE GOING TO TR DEST?
ENS OVER THIS.
TIVISTS
BACKO E VOTERS SAY
PL YOUR ONLY
CHANCE TO RE RIGHTS OPPONENTS A
FURER NOW, WE
CAN TA CONGR ABORTION
AND STAT.
I DON'T SEE  I GNG
AWAY ANYTIME>> ONE THIOO
WHEN THEION D COME
OUT, SOME OF THE REPUBNS
CAPIL  WANT TO
TALK ABOUT T ONANT TO TALK ABOU
SH.
THE MIDTERELS GOING TO
BE A, HE AOMY, INFLATION SON
ABORTICRATIC
THE DEMOCRATS, THAGE
TRA
VORSU -- THE NEXCONG SENATE INP
SUPREME CRT
CAY DOES ARISE
LL IRITY LO WE THINK
DEES CONSERVATIV
ALREADY SAIDWO
BECAUSERE  NOT PUBLIT FOR NATIO
INCOUNTRY.
THERE IS JUST
MAYBPOERSTRICTIONS, NO
OUTRIGHTS. RIGHT.
MOAT
THEIR MESSAGE, THEY HAD
BRIENG
BEF
TICISION, ANE FROMNNED
PAREHOD RSD
ABOUT THIS AND
EMOCRATS
REPUBLICANS' RESPONSE IS
COMPLEON OF ABTITHE DE THEE RS N
THE ECONOMY AS WE HAVE